let's go back to the phones let's go to
cody in somerville south carolina
brother cody how are we doing
i'm doing great excellent brother how
can i help
so i am 17 i'm about to go to college
and i feel that my family is just trying
to drain me of money
for everything so you feel like they're
draining you of money one is a feeling
one is a thought and one is an action so
tell me what's making you feel this way
oh well then it's all three okay
excellent you've asked me for so much
money
and i told them that i'm trying to go to
college like i need money for college i
need money for an apartment
and a whole plethora of things and
neither one of my parents work and have
worked for
six to seven years how did they get by
man
um i have another brother and he
works all the time and he just fell in
that sinkhole
with with them do they have any
long-term disabilities or they just
choose to not work
my mother chooses not to work but my
father he got
um he got hurt and he's waiting for
disability but
disability has apparently taken five
years
wow so i can hear almost a hint of
disgust in your voice is that fair
uh yeah that's very sorry okay so i i
didn't
at the beginning i i didn't hear you
quite right are you saying you're 17
i'm 19. oh you're 19. so do you still
live at home
um yes i still live with them okay but
i'm trying to get out of that
environment because i know that
environment is just it's horrendous
so when do you move out
that's why i'm here i wanted to ask
about when i should have
when or how i should move out and
about a lot tomorrow
why are you still there i can't just get
a place immediately i can't i don't have
enough income where are you working
right now man
i am working at a sphinx gas station
i make on average almost all the time
about 1600 amounts
get another job get two more jobs
get three more jobs what's holding you
back
um nothing really i mean the only thing
that's really holding me from the
apartment
is probably the income and it also
i feel that it would be better to you
know have a roommate help with the bills
cut them in half
i just feel that would be the best way
all right i'm gonna give you some hard
love here cody because you called me is
that cool
just a second ago i asked you did your
parents have any long-term disabilities
and you told me my mom doesn't she just
doesn't work
my dad does but evidently social
security or evidently disability takes
five years to come in
and in that sentence i heard the disgust
and the disdain and the frustration with
your old man
i heard the your disbelief
of always having an excuse my dad's
always got a reason why he's not doing a
thing
he's just saying well the check's going
to come and there's going to be this
other thing
and so here's my here's the deal cody i
heard that in you
if you really wanted your parents to
stop taking your money you would have
moved out you're 19 years old you're an
adult
you're old enough to be sent to war
you're old enough to buy smokes
you're an adult if you want out of the
situation cody get out of the situation
start tomorrow go get a second job a
third job a fourth job work like crazy
talk to your brother and say dude we've
gotta stop floating mom and dad they've
gotta
start working they don't have any reason
to go to work right now because
money just magically appears and
they're robbing you of your future
but you're always going to have an
excuse man you've got a model
in front of you of people who lay down
excuse after excuse after excuse
not to say that your old man's not hurt
man long-term disability sucks it takes
it's debilitating it takes your
soul from you it takes your dignity from
you i'm not saying
that he doesn't have some serious
challenges what i'm saying is i'm
already hearing you cody
well you know i kind of need to wait for
a roommate and then
dude just go do it man just go do it
just
go do it
tomorrow go get another job it's it's
it's in the middle of a month right now
by the middle of next month you should
have an apartment lined up you should
have a deposit saved up
go work like crazy go get it done
brother and yeah move out man
and then go to college go to a local
community college there in somerville
go find a local community college here
in south carolina get started on your
classes
go to a local trade school and make some
smoking money being a mechanic
being an air conditioned guy go to go to
school
at a local community college and get on
whatever it is you're going to be
getting on
but the day you stop putting these
barriers in front of yourself stop
inventing excuses well i need this just
go brother run
run you've got permission and freedom
and don't be a punk
to your parents they love you even if
they don't know how to show it you take
the high road treat them with dignity
treat them with
respect tell them at this time next
month i'm moving out
and they're going to say we've heard
that before cody and then you put
together your plan and you live it and
you work it out and go do it
okay after you move out cody i want you
to call me back i want you to come back
and let me know how you feel
if you feel free if you feel open if you
feel scared i want you to give me a
shout back let me know how things are
going
all right cody you can do this just go
do it
just go do it